bonjour je suis tel c'est ensemble que
nous allons découvrir l'histoire du
soulier
[Musique]
dans histoire de souliers nous allons
explorer l'univers de la chaussure
féminine de l'escarpin à la ballerine en
passant par la chaussure compenser les
bottines les bottes les mary jane
les cuissardes et toutes les autres
mais comme disait bette midler donné une
fille des chaussures correct et elle
peut conquérir le monde
dans histoire de souligner je vous dirai
tout sur cette arme de destruction et de
séduction massive les femmes et leurs
chaussures où la relation la plus
fusionnel qui soit avec un accessoire
votre vie tu ne seras avoué car la quête
du graal trouver la chaussure parfait
penchons nous sur son histoire et les
infinies possibilités offertes à
montjean aujourd'hui dans histoire de
souliers vous découvrirez d'escarpins
comment cette chaussure connue de tous
at-elle frayer son chemin à travers
l'histoire pour devenir la chaussure des
minimes par excellence avec quoi vaut-il
mieux porter l'escarpin pour retrouver
nos professionnels de la mode pour
toutes les explications avec toujours
plus d'archivés et d'expérience à
l'appui vous découvrirez ensuite les
conseils nous qui shopping de nos
professionnels qui vous révèleront les
tendances du moment
vous saurez ce qui est totalement in et
ce qui est à faire
vous retrouverez enfin notre rubrique
des modèles les plus extravagants de la
haute couture et du design nous vous
présenterons des modèles d'escarpins
pour ainsi dire uniques en leur genre
mais tout d'abord vous avez peut-être un
petit mot à nous dire sur cette
chaussure si particulière
[Musique]
paris nous avons mené notre petite
enquête dans la capitale pour savoir
comment vous abordiez l'escarpin quels
conseils mesdames je portais
essentiellement des dalons donc les
deuxièmes avec la hauteur de talon est
variable consignes l'occasion dans
l'industrie
escarpins passeport pour aller
travailler jusqu'à paris
pour moi les sens c'est comme un jeu
c'est une manière de prolonger la
personnalité
en soirée
les baux talons
à aiguilles avec une belle plateforme
devant ça fait classe et nous
commencerons aujourd'hui par le modèle
le plus féminin qui soit les escarpins
c'est à dire la petite robe noire de la
chaussure ce modèle de souliers et ce
que dita von teese est à la gente
féminine
le paroxysme du glamour en deux
mouvements il va nous faire passer de
l'état de fille lambda à celui de bombes
anatomiques près pas ravagé les coeurs
qui croiseront notre chemin mais avant
de faire perdre la tête aux hommes et
aux femmes
observons comment l'escarpin aînés
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que l'escarpin vous évoque
alors l'escarpin évoque tout de suite la
féminité le glamour glamour est le côté
aussi sexy mais ça nous évoque aussi le
confort voilà l'escarpin on peut très
bien la voir en 6 cm en 8 cm 10 cm est
aussi l'escarpin peut devenir une plate
forme parce que lescar pauvres là ça
peut être ça et ça peut aller jusqu ici
donc il ya vraiment beaucoup de
variantes de l'escarpin entre les deux
on dit souvent que l'escarpin et la
petite robe noire de la chaussure vrai
ou faux
bref vrai bien sûr sahabi énormément une
femme je veux dire on peut le mettre
on peut mettre un escarpin avec un petit
jean et tout de suite on a de l'alluré
on a un côté glamour et sexy on est
regardés c'est une vérité bien sûr donc
l'escarpin est une question d'attitude
exactement rex et par là tout compris
l'escarpin est il encore à la mode
oui l'escarpin et indémodable pour
toutes les valeurs qu'on lui a donné
pour son côté féminin pour les glamour
pour latitude pour son côté sexy c'est
vraiment la valeur sûre qui ne se démode
pas ouais t'as raison parce que c'est
vrai que nos mamans nos grands mères
tout le monde en porte est évidemment il
évolue au fil du temps les formes
évoluent le bout évolué et c'est
l'étalon aussi et les matières c'est
juste une évolution mais la base est
toujours la même et sera toujours la
même
voilà d'accord donc l'escarpin
incontournable dans nos dressings à
l'incontournable
[Musique]
je fais
pour moi l'escarpin représente la
féminité 1 bat d'escarres par bien
porter c'est c'est le sublime criminels
quand quand on était jeune et qu'on
voyait les films américains tout c'est
toutes ces stars américaines porter de
très jolis escarpins est vraiment dans
ces années-là 50-60 l'escarpin était
vraiment roi on est nous les hommes on
est toujours attiré par ce fait fini
[Musique]
oh
l'escarpin cette chaussure féminine
décolleté qui laisse apparaître le coup
de pied est apparue il ya plusieurs
siècles
son nom est emprunté de l'italien
scarpino qui signifie petite chaussure
l'escarpin habillé autrefois les vallées
qui étaient obligés de crisper leurs
pieds pour que la chaussure ne leur
échappe pas l'escarpin était alors plat
et très léger puis sous louis-philippe
les femmes commençaient à porter ces
chaussures pour les balles mais dans une
version beaucoup plus habillée vernis
est bordée d'un gallon de soi
[Musique]
c'est au xviiie siècle que les femmes
s'emparent de cette chaussure devenu
très élégante par l'ajout de ruban mais
surtout d'un talon
[Musique]
ce n'est qu'après la seconde guerre
mondiale que l'escarpin connu une montée
en puissance qui n'a jamais cessé depuis
après cette période de pénurie de
matériaux nobles la production de
l'escarpin a été lancée en italie le
berceau de la création de ce soulier
avant d'apparaître en france grâce à
l'un de nos plus grands créateurs
christian dior
[Musique]
je
présentée lors d'un défilé l'escarpin
devint alors un symbole de la féminité
mais aussi du pouvoir cette présence
très forte de l'escarpin fut encore plus
affirmée par chanel et le bottier
massaro qui lancèrent alors le fameux
modèle bicolore en cuir
[Musique]
jackie kennedy et de nombreuses femmes
de pouvoir ne sortait plus sans leur
fameuse paire d'escarpins assortis à
leur tenue après quelques années de
bouderie entre les femmes françaises et
leurs escarpins cette chaussure revient
en force dans les années 1990 et
l'escarpin retrouva son titre ô combien
jalouser de chaussure la plus féminine
qui souffrent
[Musique]
alors je vais parler de l'histoire de
l'escarpin en utilisant un escarpin
historique
donc j'ai l'honneur et le privilège
d'avoir la chaussure demeure l'ennemi
n'a donc elle a porté ce modèle là et
s'était fait par roger vivier donc une
grande bouttier française des années 60
ce qu'on voit dans cet escarpin contre
nice car pas madame donc je vais mettre
une thaïlande qui va bien c'est que
l'escarpin quand même évolué aujourd'hui
il est devenu plus échancré on est
aujourd'hui prête à montrer les doigts
de pieds 1 mais ça reste
l'incontournable de la garde de robe est
la grande différence donc pourquoi ce
que l'escarpin moderne ne ressemble plus
son ensemble c'est le technologique du
talon aujourd'hui on met dû faire une
baguette de faire dans le talon qui
donne la capacité à quelqu'un qui
produisent une chaussure le frère faire
du vrai auteur alors qu'avant avant les
talons été fait juste en bois ou en
plastique à partir des années 50 on
utilisait du plastique mais sans cette
barre ici on pouvait pas atteindre les
sommets qu'on atteint aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que l'escarpin vous évoque
alors l'escarpin disons que c'est c'est
quelque chose quand même de magique
parce qu'à la fois c'est quelque chose
qu'on met tous les jours et puis en même
temps ça a un côté assez exceptionnel
parce que suivant la hauteur de talon la
matière si jamais les champs clés ou pas
qu'on voit la naissance
justement du pied ou pas toutes ces
choses là font que c'est un modèle qui
est assez exceptionnel est emblématique
il ya une marque extrêmement peu nu avec
une semelle rouge qui en a fait un
produit extrêmement sexy nous c'est un
intemporel c'est un produit qu'on vend
toute l'année qui sert a vraiment toutes
occasions finalement et on essaye
vraiment d'avoir un produit qui soit
confortable et surtout pour moi un
escarpin ça doit être ça doit être un
peu sexy c'est vraiment une chose qui
est importante qu'on est finalement
toujours quelque chose qui soit
extrêmement sain avec un talon fin avec
finalement à chaque fois une forme
plutôt art antique pointu mais bon ça
après suivant les tendances et ben le
point tu reviens et l'arrondi sans s'en
va et puis vice versa mais voilà pour
moi vraiment d'escarpins c'est un modèle
dans une garde-robe qui est essentiel
évidemment mais surtout qui doit avoir
vraiment ce côté un peu plus sexy
bien que bon gmail man à la quasi
majorité du temps les femmes les portent
plutôt bas pour pouvoir caler toute la
journée mais c'est je pense le modèle
d'ailleurs et puis je dire une grande
marque en a fait son on a fait quasiment
un bijou alors que finalement on n'a pas
inventé grand chose mais voilà ça
vraiment quelque chose d'assez
particulier
donc l'espère pain est encore et
toujours à la mode escarpins et encore
et toujours à la mode
ce qui fait qu'à un moment peut-être un
petit peu moins le voir c'est parfois la
hauteur de talon parfois le style mais
c'est c'est intemporel
c'est là depuis depuis toujours et ce
sera là pour toujours
vraiment pour moi d'escarpins sais c'est
quelque chose de vivant classement c'est
vraiment quelque chose de deux
magnifiques escarpins je pense que c'est
un modèle incontournable
toutes les femmes en désirent un dans
leur collection de chaussures au moins
une paire et c'est un modèle qu'on
visitera en permanence l'escarpin est un
type de chaussures plutôt apprécié des
créateurs de haute couture et des
designers surtout dans les collections
estivales
et il faut reconnaître que sa
spécificité d'ajouter de la hauteur et
de sublimer le dessus du pied entre
alors que les possibilités de création
hors du commun en tant que chaussures
éminemment classé féminine il n'est pas
étonnant de retrouver régulièrement
l'escarpin dans les défilés les plus
grands comme dans les expérimentations
des nouveaux talents de la mode comme à
son habitude le controversé alexander
mcqueen fait encore plus dans la
provocation en réinventant l'escarpin
sous la forme de modèles aliens
complètement déjanté mais dans une
inspiration un peu plus classique
il poursuit avec des escarpins en
dentelle blanche et une simple tête de
mort sur le dessus chez castelbajac
nous retrouvons un modèle qui accumule
les codes baroque liant avec complexité
il
coquillages traces et dorures ou au
contraire en collaboration avec la
marque mellow yellow un escarpin à
l'effigié de mickey le personnage de
l'univers enfantin de disney de son côté
stella mccartney propose des escarpins
entièrement recouvert de paillettes
dorées avec une sortie de cole noir en
contraste ainsi que quelques escarpins
sobre et de couleurs vives unis doté
d'un talent on dort et incrusté de
strass a sorti un de nos créateurs
phares en france christian louboutin a
décidé de donner vie aux escarpins de
cendrillon avec sa fameuse touche
généreuse en décoration jugez plutôt par
vous même ces autres escarpins de sa
conception
pierre agencé selon des motifs exotiques
cloud modèle presque totalement
transparent ou bien encore cet audacieux
modèle arc en ciel en hommage au peintre
jackson pollock charlotte olympia quant
à elle nous présente un modèle tout
simple noir et mat avec comme détail
original une tête de chat brodé sur la
pointe
anastasia devise est une créatrice de
chaussures à l'origine d'une collection
intitulée lost civilizations qui vise à
retranscrire l'altération des
civilisations avec des matières évoquant
des formes de vies disparues
et c'est dans sa collection de 2011
nommé sooner or later que la créatrice
excentrique parme et revol présente des
modèles tout à fait amusant incluant des
mains ou bien mettant en abyme la
chaussure dans le talent
parmi les escarpins de chez kobi levi
designer reconnu pour ses modèles
originaux à tendance ludique et inspirés
du quotidien
on retrouve par exemple c'est
intelligent modèle la forme d'oiseau
[Musique]
enfin la marque hercules offshore joue
sur la profusion des détails sur des
chaussures aux couleurs acidulées et
évocatrice de l'enfance il va jusqu'à 8h
et des petits personnages en porte-clés
[Musique]
montpetit conseils shopping pour bien
choisir ses escarpins
alors mesdames il y à deux voix soit
d'escarpins bouts pointus soual
escarpins à bouts ronds
alors pour le coup aujourd'hui j'ai
choisi de mettre un escarpin bouts
pointus en poils léopard alors oui vous
avez dire que j'ai du zèbre mais
justement aujourd'hui je suis pander
voilà on l'a ressorti tout à l'heure
j'ai adoré et c'est exactement ça c'est
vraiment sympa aujourd'hui de mixer deux
animaux différents
donc j'ai de la panthère et si j'ai du
zèbre donc voila vous allez me dire que
c'est un peu too much mais absolument
pas hyper tendance c'est hyper jolie
donc pour le coup c'est vrai que les
pieds flash énormément mais on vous
repèrent très très loin alors là est par
contre il faut l'assumer
si on veut partir dans quelque chose
d'un peu plus sobre alors on peut très
bien se faire un modèle bouts pointus en
total look glitter noir donc c'est vrai
que c'est hyper sympa aujourd'hui le
glitter est vraiment actuelle grâce à
mieux mieux notamment
voilà on a une petite une petite jupe
comme moi aujourd'hui en panthère encore
avec des petits glitter au pied c'est
vrai qu'on est très original mais on
garde un peu ce côté sobre pour le coup
si on opte par exemple pour un escarpin
mourront en total look glitter alors là
c'est vrai quand on joue sur la bi
coloris tu es donc là ça se remarque
énormément mieux vaut partir sur une
tenue assez sobre c'est vrai qu'il faut
quand même le glitter l'assumer
énormément donc peut-être être plus
sobre en eau pour bien voir les pieds
lescar point vous habillera ne vous
inquiétez pas ou alors même ça a été dit
notamment par un homme mais je suis tout
à fait d'accord
la cordée avec un petit jean slim kitai
parfaitement de jolies fesses bien
galbées avec l'escarpin ça sera parfait
un petit marcel blanc et là on est au
top et on est au top du fashion ou alors
si on a un petit peu peur d'être trop
clinquante
on peut opter pour un cuir lisse avec un
talon de 6 cm donc là pour le coup
parfait pour la marche et on a un peu
plus discrète un peu plus sobre mais on
peut quand même la corde et à petite
touche de folie avec
dieter blanc donc là c'est de la fim
payet donc c'est vraiment quand même
assez discret et là ont la corde avec sa
tenue tous les jours un jean encore où
ça peut être son petit tailleur pour
aller travailler etc
on garde quand même une touche
d'originalité au pied ce qui est
important mais d'abord pour se démarquer
tous les jours qui est vraiment à la
mode cet été c'est le petit escarpins à
bouts ronds qui fait un peu mais mise un
peu femme enfant en rose nude un rosé
new donc c'est vraiment la tendance nude
était hier à peu près un an et demi
c'est aujourd'hui c'est plutôt le vieux
rose mais qui tourne quand même vers le
belge
on voit là c'est sympa au pied une
petite couleur de peau un peu bronzé et
on est au top avec une petite robe
blanche un petit peu fluide et cetera
c'est vrai qu'on se fait remarquer en
même temps en étant sobre assez
sensuelle et un peu enfin si comme il
faut le taire mon conseil shopping sur
l'escarpin c'est de respirer la féminité
et idéalement avec une jolie jupe
alors comment choisir un bel escarpins
non on peut pas mettre tout et n'importe
quoi ça absolument pas ça dépend de la
cambrure de la personne ça dépend de la
largeur du pied de la personne et de ce
qu'elle pourra supporter en hauteur
alors c'est vrai qu'on fait tout auteur
/ l'escarpin mais tout le monde ne peut
pas porter encore une fois n'importe
quoi parce que l'idée c'est
effectivement que l'acs que la personne
porte un escarpin mais d'être aussi
confort si c'est juste pour aller
traverser la rue non moi je suis contre
les couleurs préférées de l'escarpin
c'est déjà en numéro 1 le noir il faut
avoir un bel escarpins noirs ça c'est
sûr et ensuite on peut accessoirisé en
nude en argent et dans les couleurs un
petit peu pastel mêmes couleurs
acidulées toutes les couleurs sont jolis
parce que toutes les couleurs sont
tendance dans la mode
les boues sont pointus obligatoire
d'avoir une boule pointu donc c'est
commencer l'année dernière et cette
année ça va être coupée l'a donc même
moi je les cupr est là et on voit le
début des désormais et ça c'est la
tendance je dirais le plus fort pour
2013 il y a plein de paradoxes dans la
vie et l'escarpin chose une fille mal
c'est très difficile de tenir sur son
pied comme résultat les filles ont
tendance à prendre une taille trop
petite pour elle avec une souffrance
horrible c'est une chaussure qui chausse
mal on peut faire deux choses fort et
corrigé par contre on peut mettre une
bride décoratifs donc ça détourne un peu
une escarpins mais une chose qui est
facile et beaucoup de filles le fait pas
donc j'en profite c'est si on rajoute
une insert là là où il y à l'arche du
pied on joue avec le volume intérieur de
l'étape 1 et on arrive à une escarpins
qui serait quasiment parfaite et la
fille va être ravie et plus belle et
plus belle en jouant juste une tout
petit peu avec sept volumes
elle va être plus belle dans son
instinct si on regarde haute couture on
est devenu plus épuré cet été beaucoup
plus mines emil list est aussi beaucoup
plus classique donc dans la haute
couture c'est ça qu'on trouve et ce qui
m'a sidéré donc c'est commencer chez
céline l'année d'un
mais s'est confirmée sur beaucoup de
podiums pour cet été il ya beaucoup de
blancs et saigne blanc pior et c'est une
vraie blanc donc ça c'est le chose que
je vois je vois un peu le fond d'eux les
couleurs neutres qui est omniprésente
maintenant depuis dix ans et cette
notion de blanc noir l'argent commence à
revenir et beaucoup de transparence est
bizarrement on parle de jaune depuis des
années et cette année ça me donne envie
donc cet été je vais tenter d'y jaune
canard et quels sont vos conseils pour
bien acheter son escarpin alors bien
acheté son escarpin la première chose
déjà le confort parce que finalement
c'est une chaussure aujourd'hui qui se
doit d'être confortable en tant que
fabricant chaussures nous aujourd'hui à
des techniques au niveau de la cambrure
au niveau 2 des petites choses
je pense que c'est important et puis ce
que je trouve particulièrement joli mois
dans un escarpin c'est vraiment là
lorsqu'il est extrêmement échancré et
qu'on voit vraiment la naissance des
boîtiers ça donne vraiment un côté
extrêmement sexy donc moi c'est vraiment
les choses que qui sont importants pour
moi dans un escarpin alors petit
récapitulatif des conseils de nos
professionnels concernant l'escarpin
mesdames n'hésitez plus pour être
tendance est aux et les textures en tout
genre que vous soyez plutôt payet plutôt
poils d'animaux ou les deux surtout ne
vous privez pas la tendance est à
l'audacieux les modèles de couleur peau
ou nude comme on dit du roseau beige ses
escarpins simple se montrait discrète et
c'est l'occasion de mettre plutôt
l'accent sur d'éventuels éléments
décoratifs un petit nos par exemple les
modèles échancrure pour un effet sexy
garantie en revanche évitez les très
petites annonces s'il est une chaussure
qui peut allier hauteur et conforter
bien l'escarpin profiter sans si vous
vous sentez hauteur d'associer une paire
de chaussures hautes en couleur avec une
tenue elle aussi très original
ne mettez pas les regard d'autrui à
l'épreuve et contentez-vous de la
sobriété d'un jean et d'un débardeur
si vos escarpins sont plutôt extravagant
on conclusion l'escarpin est un
incontournable à posséder dans nos
placards qu'il soit à bout rond point tu
que son talent soit 2,4 ou de 12 cm
l'escarpin trouvera toujours une place
dans nos tenues
n'hésitez pas à le mixer à vos pantalons
de smoking jean petite robe fleurie en
bref il va avec tout pour ne pas se
tromper
choisissez-le en cuir noir et vous n'en
serez jamais déçu quelques conseils
cependant pour ne pas vous retrouver
fâché avec votre paire d'escarpins
puisque l'escarpin sera un des meilleurs
alliés de vos tenues fait le pari
d'investir
il n'y a rien de pire qu'une paire
d'escarpins qui vous fait mal aux pieds
et vous donne du coup une démarche
ridicule
fuyez comme la peste les cuir
synthétique et choisissez un cuir
confortable et souple marché quelques
pas en boutique pour vérifier que le
confort sera à la hauteur du temps que
vous allez passer avec vos escarpins à
vos pieds et si vous escarpins en cuir
vous font mal aux pieds les premiers
jours je vais vous donner une astuce
diablement efficace mouiller une paire
de chaussettes fine essorer les ai
enfilé les sur vos pieds avant de porter
vos escarpins à faire un soir où vous
êtes seul à la maison naturellement ce
n'est absolument pas sexy mais ça marche
terriblement l'humidité de la paire de
chaussettes assouplira le cuir qui
prendra de suite la forme de vos pieds
et bien sûr puisque avoir du style c'est
aussi soigné les détails n'hésitez pas à
entretenir généreusement le cuir de veau
escarpins et à leur offrir une seconde
jeunesse chez le cordonnier
quand leur talent on sera un peu fatigué
je vous garantis que vos escarpins vous
rendront bien les efforts que vous ferez
pour eux à bientôt pour la suite
d'histoires de souliers
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]